...
-Pour faire ce reportage
sur les loisirs,
..j'ai choisi la périphérie
de Paris, les endroits..
..où s'édifient, ces grands
ensembles et où on trouve,
..sur un minimum de surface
le maximum de jeunes.
-Quel est le problème numéro un
dans cette cité dortoirs, l'ennui ?
-C'est le thème..
..de l'émission :
ces jeunes s'ennuient..
..et on les voit
au milieu des blocs,
..dès qu'ils ont du temps,
se promener sur leurs mobylettes..
..et errer à la grande frayeur de
la population. Ils sont souvent 2..
..sur leurs mobylettes,
ce qui est interdit.
-Ils se promènent, comme ça,
gratuitement ? Ils vont..
..d'un endroit à un autre,
ils font le tour... ?
-Oui, ils n'ont rien
d'autre à faire.
-Des moyens sont mis
à leur disposition ?
-Ils vont vous en parler.
-Quels sont..
..vos distractions dans un grand
ensemble, comme ici, à Epinay ?
-Cinéma,
..maison de jeunes,
elle n'est pas terrible, mais...
A part le club, là,
mais peu y vont.
Et c'est tout, je crois.
-Vous vous ennuyez ?
-Beaucoup. On a le flipper.
[Brouhaha,
ambiance du bistrot.]
...
Il faut débourser,
..et c'est tout,
on n'a rien à faire.
-Vous ne restez jamais
avec vos parents, le soir ?
-C'est pas intéressant,
c'est des croulants.
-Quelle part de l'argent
que vous gagnez vous consacrez..
..à vos loisirs ?
Toi, tu gagnes combien ?
-10 000 francs par semaine,
à peu près, 250 francs de l'heure.
J'ai 500 F tous les jours
pour manger et 1000 F le dimanche.
-Tu en donnes à tes parents ?
-Oui, je donne le reste.
Ca fait 3 000 F par semaine.
-Il te reste combien par semaine
pour des distractions ?
-1 000 francs.
-Tu fais quoi avec ça ?
-Ils sont partis le samedi soir
et le dimanche je suis fauché.
-Tu en dépenses beaucoup,
pour les flippers, par exemple ?
-Trois quarts.
...
-Trois quarts dans les flippers ?
-Oui.
-Et le reste, cinéma ?
-Le reste...
Un coup aux copains,
ou bien...
Cinéma, c'est les autres
qui payent toujours.
-Vous faites quoi
quand vous êtes en bande ?
-On se promène,
..on chahute...
-Vous faites des bêtises ?
-Rarement.
-Ca vous arrive ?
-Oui, mais très rarement.
-Quelle sorte de bêtise ?
-Quand on fait du bruit
avec les mobylettes.
-Les mobylettes, comment
vous vous les êtes payées ?
-C'est mes parents
qui me l'ont payée.
-En travaillant ?
-Oui.
-A crédit ?
-Oui, en payant à crédit,
chaque mois.
-Je suis apprenti
electro-mécanicien.
J'ai pas tellement de loisirs :
le soir, je rentre à 21h,
..car je vais à l'école,
parce que ils ne veulent plus..
..me prendre dans l'école
où j'étais. Sinon, comme loisir,
..j'ai le samedi et dimanche
avec les copains,
..le flipper.
-Doucement, tu vas faire tilt !
-Vous restez le soir
avec vos parents ?
-RAREMENT.
-Toi, par exemple ?
-Moi, je sors toujours le soir.
-Pourquoi ?
-Les parents...
Toujours des discussions...
-On s'accorde pas.
-Non, on n'a pas les mêmes idées.
-Tu as quoi comme idée
que n'a pas ton père ?
-Quand je lui dis :
"J'aurais passé mon permis",
..il me dit : "Non,
t'es encore trop jeune,
"..à ton âge
j'avais pas de voiture..."
Alors, c'est terminé.
-Qu'as-tu comme loisirs ?
-On va au cinéma,
au café, on fait des flippers.
-En fait, vous vous ennuyez ?
-OUI.
-Merci.
-On y va.
[Ils démarrent leurs mobylettes.]
...
-Est-ce qu'ils s'ennuieraient moins
s'ils habitaient dans un vieux..
..quartier de Paris ?
-Je crois, oui,
parce que...
On a tourné à la Courneuve.
Le moins qu'on puisse dire..
..de ces grands ensembles,
..c'est qu'ils manquent d'âme.
On a construit,
..on a paré au plus pressé.
Et le problème des loisirs..
..de ces jeunes,
a été un peu...
Non pas la dernière roue
du carrosse. On n'a pas eu..
..le temps d'y penser.
-Mais c'est plus clair,
..les appartements
sont plus vastes.
Que manque-t-il ?
-D'abord d'une part..
..des maisons des jeunes..
..et de la culture.
Ici, à la Courneuve,
..2 cafés se sont installés..
..où on trouve les fameux flippers
dont vous entendez parler souvent..
..dans cette émission.
La maison des jeunes,
le gros oeuvre est terminé.
Mais pour qu'on puisse
aménager l'intérieur,
..on attend
un feu vert préfectoral..
..qui tarde peut-être un peu
à venir depuis quelques mois.
La nouvelle préfecture
qui doit s'installer..
..dans le nord de la banlieue
parisienne avait envisagé..
..d'y installer ses services
administratifs, mais le projet..
..a été abandonné.
Mais en attendant,
..ici, il n'y a pas
de maison des jeunes.
-Celle-ci n'est pas en service.
-Absolument pas.
Alors,
comme ils n'ont rien à faire,
..ils s'ennuient
et ils sont livrés à l'oisiveté,
..ils se promènent le soir
dans le centre commercial.
Et nous avons suivi,
caméra sur l'épaule,
..trois de ces garçons.
Vous allez les voir.
-C'est pas intéressant.
-Toujours au café !
Ca va bien un moment,
..mais après...
-Tous les soirs, c'est pas bon.
C'est pas une question de ça,
..mais ce n'est pas une vie
pour un jeune.
Le café c'est bien beau, mais...
-Regarde-le,
..il n'oublie pas de manger,
celui-là.
-Bonjour.
On aurait bien une distraction,
ce serait de faire du cheval.
-Tiens, regarde !
-Ca va, Serge ?
-Enchanté.
Qu'est ce que vous faîtes?
Que veux-tu faire
dans le quartier ?
-T'as des sous ?
-On se balade.
-C'est à 18h que qu'il
revient du boulot, Jackie ?
-Oui.
-Dimanche, on fait quoi ?
-On va au cinéma.
-En définitive,
comme personne ne résout..
..le problème de leurs loisirs
au niveau où ils le souhaitent,
..les jeunes essaient
de les organiser, leurs loisirs,
..comme ils peuvent
et en l'occurrence..
..ils les organisent dans la cave.
-Ils ont pu utiliser,
..à la Courneuve,
des locaux qui étaient..
..des garages pour vélos.
Et ils les ont transformés
en un local qu'ils ont décoré,
..d'ailleurs,
très agréablement.
Et c'est là qu'ils se réunissent
le samedi, le dimanche pour danser,
..car comme ils organisent
eux-mêmes leurs loisirs,
..ils les organisent selon
leur désir. Il n'est pas question..
..de loisirs intellectuels,
alors ils sont là et ils dansent.
-Mais quand ils prennent une
initiative, c'est à ce seul niveau.
-Exactement.
[Musique.]
...
-En regardant ces images,
on n'a pas l'impression que..
..c'est tellement,
on on l'a dit trop souvent,
..la violence ou l'érotisme
qu'ils recherchent. C'est plutôt..
..la solidarité,
le fait d'être ensemble.
-Le problème des loisirs
des jeunes,
..c'est un problème de
regroupements. Ils ont besoin..
..de se regrouper entre eux.
Ils n'aiment pas être seuls,
..ils n'aiment pas tellement
rester avec leurs parents.
...
-C'est en fait dans la bande
qu'ils arrivent le mieux..
..à vaincre cet ennui
dont on parlait au début.
-Oui, la bande pas tellement
au sens péjoratif, d'ailleurs.
-Vous venez souvent
au Surprise Party ?
-Assez souvent,
quand il y en a une.
-Y en a une tous les combien ?
-Ca dépend. Maintenant,
..tous les dimanche,
on en fait une.
-Le samedi aussi ?
-Non, le samedi je travaille.
-Que faites-vous ?
-Je suis secrétaire médicale,
..et j'apprends le métier de
manipulatrice chez un radiologue.
-Et qu'avez-vous
comme autres distractions ?
-Après, c'est le cinéma,
mais en premier la danse.
-Vous pensez qu'on s'occupe
assez des loisirs des jeunes..
..dans les grands ensembles ?
-Je ne pense pas, non.
Ce sont plutôt les jeunes
qui essaient..
..de s'arranger quelque chose.
Sinon, je vois que..
..les grandes personnes
ne s'en occupent pas.
Au contraire.
-Cette cave, vous l'êtes..
..organisée entre copains ?
-Oui.
On a fait tout notre possible..
..pour se retrouver le dimanche,
car c'est le seul jour..
..où on se voit,
les autres jours on travaille.